are you consuming like any comedy as a
fan because Netflix drops it feels like
two or three specials a week at this
point like are you are you tapping into
like other comedian specials just to
kind of see what they're doing or no no
no I I tell comedians I had this one
rule never watch another comic um
you could
take a peek but never watch another
comic because maybe subconsciously
something happens there that you don't
you watch yep you watch them and they
funny and the next thing you know you
either flip a joke
or you got they style and if you ever
watched my stand and my shit's so cold
that it might have said it best he said
you still TK Kirkland [__] you know it's
TK because nobody talks the way I talk
or think the way that I think and when
in the 90s
when I was trying to pursue HBO going to
meetings show time going to meetings
because that was kind of like the that
was the Pinnacle of Comedy like getting
there and I was always my mindset was
always ahead of my time being
independent and you kids came along and
I always knew in the 90s that my career
was going to change based on youngsters
like you because I didn't know what it
was I didn't I didn't know there was
gonna be podcast right I didn't know
there was gonna be this streaming thing
I just knew something was going to
happen I said my world is going to
change when the young kids get older and
then bam we have this new life and
entertainment you know like now I have
my own network right right I don't have
to go to HBO I don't have to go to
Netflix but most convenience will
consider brainwashed I gotta do Netflix
I gotta have my show that's true but I
do my own [__] making my own money like
you said like an independent rapper yeah
it feels like the comedy
um
I guess the
measurables of what makes you a
successful comedian is changing now
because because now you'll see guys like
Andrew scholes or Joe Rogan or the 85
South guys yes and they're have they
have their own platform that's way
bigger than any Netflix show yes that's
bigger than doing a special and selling
it like I think Andrew scholes went he
probably I mean he made millions of
dollars I did a show a couple years ago
it's good to see what he's done but I do
the same thing so it's like it's like it
feels like that at least the tide is
turning in the comedy World in terms of
like
back in the day you almost had to have a
sitcom or or catch a movie Yes or catch
one of those roles to kind of be
considered like and what you guys are
these podcasts that taper do your thing
you guys are the the new Arsenio Hall
shows the new David Letterman right see
because back then the only shows you
could get on and you would only have
like three or four minutes at a time
exactly as opposed to sit down for an
hour and people really know exactly the
world watches yeah the world Listen to
My podcast the world Listen to Black
Girl listens to The Breakfast Club you
know so
um it's really down to honors it's been
a blessing for me